geoffrey sera peut-être l'un des deux
jeunes en service civique à la
préfecture des yvelines se mord pas bien
de 25 ans actuellement en recherche
d'emploi s'engagerait pour huit mois
j'ai fait un communication donc avec la
préfecture les tâches qu'elle me donnait
ça aurait pu ça peut être très
intéressant en adéquation avec ce que je
fais ça va être sympa après moi je
cherche pas un temps plein donc c'est
pour ça que le service civique ça peut
se mettre au dessus donc ça me laissera
du temps de faire des choses à côté pour
ce service civique des teens le réseau
information jeunesse des yvelines a
convié une vingtaine d'organismes du
territoire de 100 missions sont
proposées pour des jeunes de 16 à 25 ans
il peut avoir un amalgame sur l'emploi
donc c'est donc c'est pour ça que
j'insiste 1 c'est bien une mission en
tant que volontaire il donc il ya
beaucoup de communication a porté sur
qu'est ce que le service civique et
après c'est de les diriger vers la bonne
structure parce qu'un jeune peut faire
qu'une fois service civique dans sa vie
des services d'état des établissements
scolaires mais aussi des associations
comme celle ci installé à viroflay
elle développe depuis 2015 un gant
connectés et propose deux missions
autour du marketing et de l'innovation
sans le service civique il serait
impossible pour nous de pouvoir
développer aussi facilement en fait ce
type de prototype ce qu'on souhaite
aussi c'est que la personne
à terme elle puisse trouver plus
facilement son emploi et peut-être même
si notre association réussi à proposer
cette allée jusqu'au stade d'un produit
lui permettre de même de l'embauché des
missions dans les yvelines en france et
même à l'étranger en 2016 plus de 90
mille volontaires ont réalisé un service
civique